hello and welcome to see you playing
Jack Daniels pin para el mal 18 25 91
yeah that's a good reading we try this
one has a funky idea I think black is
quite okay here in the sky this is
opening looks a bit strange good night
before here's a good idea yeah both
sides nights it look a little bit
strange Oh is he going for be five year
but I don't really think can be
dangerous okay hiya okay maybe he has
something but I don't don't quite get it
I know that just looks weakening for
white or what is the idea some dynamics
that I don't understand probably you're
okay we might go for some if only I
don't know let's go back Bishop before
they may be also f 3 and so on
yeah I cannot move here on the queenside
so easily 96 could be could be coming
but still I mean I have a look FC aid
and probably see for some problem no and
didn't play that okay if I go look-see
for here and i would like to prevent you
for here absolutely I might have night
before though like before and then
taking so it's not not a threat sturrock
c4 is got a phone currently c4 is not a
threat 9 p-8 to c6 to a 5 but that's
that's a really yeah a long line looks
you for taking too long here as Eve from
light 98 is e 4
okay before I know if I want to go okay
for then it might be complete rubbish
that's a powerful-looking move I don't
quite understand it though okay so why
can I not take on it to attend because
of nights it's real what's the prob
what's the deal s'okay for a look a 21
sorry Knight c3 hmm okay the knight
Knight c3 is a thread anyway so okay
let's let's trade some stuff
9c success d 5 that's probably happening
anyway I got night chief no 95 TX Queen
takes us not good a six maybe a six
takes takes I don't have enough time
here spending too long and I will be
looking stuff yes supered I simply
simply blundered into this oh my bad
yeah it's immediately lost home probably
I know I'm in this fishery okay come on
that's useless time horny resins and it
was stupid I'm not sure what the
position is like engine gives equal
after g5 but yeah okay let's playing
like super quickly and having saving
some pressure didn't understand many
moves though and thought anyway so here
you'll see it and here I took ages for
that move Roxy for hmm it was letters is
a difficult position you can really yeah
it's a position to spend some time but
not that much this one night to be four
is an interesting move that the computer
gives and didn't see it ok this one in
our if I for strong yeah this is this is
not leading to anything
five is the move that the computer
recommends now this kind of stuff is
difficult to find now it wants to play
this variation which is completely
inhuman can't forget about that I might
be okay yeah but if I need this this
kind of moves it it is it is a tricky
tricky business happy five yeah wyd
retain some some pressure here really
does never solve this idea it's not easy
to play him this is very logical and
Lucas afore I ultimately didn't find
other other moves if I play something
like this he plays you for I mean does
this would make some sense and generally
speaking trying to trade stuff but he's
gotta foreign so i probably have to play
this but i didn't see this move and this
is probably the move i have to play no
this looks kind of okay what the engine
gives now tough enjoy it rather looks
good for Wyatt but yeah it's a at least
it looks better than the game yeah
anyway good game here by mr. Jack
Daniels thanks for watching